salut à tous la semaine passée j'ai reçu
une demande un peu particulière j'ai été
contacté par une personne de l'équipe
d'arnaud boissières qui est un skipper
de ouf du vendée globe qui mal y voit là
arnaud aime beaucoup ce que tu fais là
par les besoins dans une interview
est-ce que tu serais hockey de lui faire
une surprise c'est à dire on lui dit
rien lui prépare un petit message
d'encouragement et on lui envoie là-bas
sur son bateau en plein milieu des mers
australes
j'ai trouvé l'idée trop cool je me suis
dit quoi de mieux pour encourager une
personne qui est en train de faire le
vendée globe que de les chanter une
petite chanson je vous laisse découvrir
ce que ça donne j'ai reçu un message
d'une équipe qui m'a envoyé une petite
vidéo que j'ai téléchargé
ils m'ont demandé de l'écouter
c'est dû à renens c'est vous
tu es fan de moi
que sur ton bateau bleu et je ne me
coûte trop large dans le froid ton
équipe a donc contacté pour que je
t'envoie que mme une étoile une petite
chanson pour te guider et aider à garder
le moral avec plaisir je joue le jeu
m
il marche unie
pour aider les gens plus on aimerait
8es
et tu vas perdre arnaud boissières il
vaut mieux que tu rentres maintenant
tout l'acharné à quoi ça sert tu seras
gagner comme tous les ans tu vois bien
que les pâtes ont créé nombre bien plus
tu aimes dans l'eau tu pourras toujours
voir l'été du pédalo à noirmoutier de
toute façon c'est quoi ce sport ou 30
arrêts lutte contre la mort chaque jour
pour finalement revenir vivant en vend
des cons c'est pire disparaît tout à
coup en mer quand c'est la même partout
sur terre il faut quand même bien à vous
et vous souhaite une belle bande
doublant ker tour sérieux un moment et
prenant tous un peu de recul
qu'est ce que c'est que ces connards
printemps même blessure sont ridicules
quand clarisse appel en urgence lors
d'une tempête s'était laissé non et
c'est juste ça c'est pas de chance
brûler la chatte avec santé quand jean
s'est gravement au visage s'est-il
orthez
entendre nos phrases non il s'est juste
pris dernièrement dans la coupe des
poissons volants
si ça continue tu ne sais par d'autres
marsa
ta gueule tu te laissera avec ton bonnet
ou tu prendras un crabe dans l'oeil au
mieux tu devras faire un char hier pour
repêcher un autre
qui sait pas tenir trois jours mer sans
piller on eu son voilier
je te dirais bien quand tu reviendras on
se prendra fin vers mais en vrai mara en
manque depuis deux mois
franchement je préférais n'était en
revanche au pl lost était jeté
manu je viendrai il ya une chance sur de
toute façon
que tu coules avant de voir cette
chanson
excellent
se fout de ma gueule d'ailleurs
faire plaisir ni aux razziés gars
et on en exemple
j'adore